vous connaissez certainement autour de
vous des personnes qui sortent de
l'université sans vraiment savoir quoi
faire sur un petit peu sa tête là qui
dans certains cas n'ont carrément aucun
plan de vie de carrière et qui
malheureusement dans d'autres cas
laissent tomber leurs rêves pour se
diriger vers des carrières qui leur
semble accessible
peut-être avez-vous remarqué que
certains de vos amis ou connaissances
professionnelles se laisse porter avec
ennui dans une carrière qui ne les
satisfait pas qu'il n'aime pas voir
qu'il déteste
peut-être est-ce même votre cas et
comment ça se fait c'est parce
qu'aujourd'hui beaucoup de personnes qui
consciemment ou inconsciemment sont
passés à côté de leur vocation pense
qu'elles sont bloquées
elles se disent qu'elles n'ont que deux
options dans la vie être payés à faire
un job qu'elle n'aime pas ou bien être
libre mais ne pas toucher de salaire ou
seulement un salaire insuffisant pour
vivre de façon confortable on va dire
ces personnes là elles ont raison de
penser comme ça mais plus pour très
longtemps
en réalité si ça se passe comme ça c'est
pour deux raisons premièrement le
système éducatif actuel est en panne en
panne qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut
dire que avant avoir un master c'était
prestigieux aujourd'hui avoir un master
ce n'est plus exceptionnel
ce n'est pas un moyen de se démarquer
des autres personnes vraiment peut
frimer aujourd'hui avec un master
pourquoi parce que malheureusement ce
n'est pas du tout une garantie de
trouver un emploi et deuxièmement le
monde du travail est en profonde
mutation
les entreprises se retrouvent un peu
schizophrène partagé entre conserver un
business model qui les a amenés à
réussir et embrasser s'adapter un monde
en mouvement et en plus de ça elles ont
d'énormes difficultés à trouver chez les
individus les compétences nécessaires
pour aborder le 21e siècle alors ces
constats laissent prédire deux choses
fondamentales qui vont arriver dans le
monde professionnel de demain des
métiers inédits vont apparaître
je suis sûr que vous en êtes témoins et
on en a vu ce soir il y à des personnes
qui exercent aujourd'hui des fonctions
qui n'existaient pas il ya encore cinq
ans et cette tendance se généralise
grâce au numérique notamment on l'a vu
demain par exemple vous serez peut-être
consultant en vie privée vous révéler
les failles qui met en péril la vie
personnelle physiques ou virtuels des
individus
demain vous serez peut-être croque-mort
digital vous gèrerez du contenu en ligne
pour rendre les dernières volontés des
individus et de leur famille sur
internet à titre posthume demain vous
serez peut-être numéro pâte spécialiste
des addictions technologique
vous aiderez les individus techno
stressé à se déconnecter de leur
appareil grâce à une cure de
désintoxication digital mais demain vous
serez peut-être autre chose parce que
ses trois métiers ne sont que des
exemples
et la liste est longue et ne cesse de se
réinventer deuxièmement de nombreux
métiers vont disparaître et certainement
le vôtre les machines les technologies
le numérique l'internet remplace
progressivement l'homme dans de très
nombreuses fonctions ça se voit déjà
aujourd'hui technicien en tous genres
ouvriers agriculteurs médecins demain
avocats fonctionnaires tour opérateurs
agents immobiliers et j'en passe grosso
modo dites vous bien que si un programme
informatique un site internet où une
technologie quelconque est capable ou
sera capable de faire votre métier
demain alors préparez-vous à changer de
métier
coincé dans cette transition des métiers
nous vivons à l'échelle globale ce que
nous pensons être une crise et nous
avons raison de penser que c'est une
crise parce que les taux de chômage sont
là pour le rappeler
mais même si les gouvernements de
nombreux pays promettent une baisse du
chômage
d'après les experts du numérique et
notamment le français gilles babinet
cela n'arrivera pas car en réalité on
fonce droit vers une ère du vide
emploi le vide emploi le contraire du
plein emploi
ça fait peur le vix d'emploi parce que
ces inconnus c'est inédit et ça pose
question
que sommes-nous censés faire dans une
vie où notre temps n'est plus structurée
en fonction de ce que nous avons besoin
de faire pour vivre
qu'est ce que ça implique exactement
nous sommes en train de nous diriger
vers une société dans laquelle la
richesse économique n'est plus
directement créés par l'homme mais ce
n'est pas si grave que cela je dois vous
rassurer parce que ce n'est pas l'emploi
qui se vide
c'est le travail demain ce sera la
machine qui fera le travail qui fera ce
qui est fatiguant ce qui est pénible ce
qui est insatisfaisant ce qui est
rébarbatif et qui a fortiori fera quand
même aussi la richesse économique le pib
le travail au sens étymologique du terme
en latin tripalium qui signifie
instrument de torture
nora demain pour l'homme plus de sens
plus de valeur et plus d'utilité
qu'adviendra-t-il alors de l'homme
habitué à travailler depuis la nuit des
temps
pensez vous qu'il deviendra paresseux
pensez vous qu'il deviendra oisifs
complètement désoeuvrés si nous ne
travaillons plus demain qu'est-ce qu'il
nous restera à faire
qu'est-ce qu'il nous restera eh bien il
nous restera ce qu'il y a de plus humain
en nous il nous restera par exemple
l'intelligence il nous restera
l'empathie et probablement toujours la
volonté de changer le monde
rené crevel un des théoriciens du
transhumanisme prédit qu'avec l'avancée
des technologies de plus en plus
d'individus auront la possibilité de
consacrer leur vie à leur passion nous
allons enfin pouvoir faire ce qui nous
passionne
sans se poser la question de savoir si
nous pouvons en vivre ce qui nous semble
impossible aujourd'hui va devenir
accessible demain le travail va devenir
source d'épanouissement
on ne parlera d'ailleurs certainement
plus du mot travail et c'est le mot
emplois qui va retrouver toute sa
pertinence dans sa définition
c'est à dire employés utiliser son temps
consacré sa vie à sa passion pour créer
quelque chose et laisser sa marque
la trace de son passage sur terre le
travail est mort explique heures une
société idéale c'est une société dans
laquelle personne n'occupe une sphère
d'activité exclusive mais où chacun a la
possibilité de s'épanouir dans le
domaine de son choix
faire une chose un jour est complètement
autre chose le lendemain vous savez qui
a dit ça karl marx et c'est formidable
parce que ça veut dire que s'il ne
serait-ce qu'une fraction de la
population a la possibilité de main de
fer de faire ce qu'elle aime et qu'elle
n'est plus obligé de 9h à 18h de faire
un travail pénible et difficile alors le
futur risque d'être plein d'art plein de
beauté plein d'invention plein de
créativité et sans doute plein
d'humanité
alors je suis sûr maintenant vous vous
dites ok c'est vrai certains individus
feront ça mais les autres profiteront
seulement des inventions créé par les
premiers peut-être et alors
c'est bientôt le futur mais en attendant
c'est le présent tout cela va devenir
accessible mais pas tout de suite il ne
suffit pas d'attendre que cela arrive
de nombreux défis vont venir compliquer
l'arrivée du futur de l'emploi la
transition va être très rude
elle est déjà très rude pour certains il
ya notamment deux défis éthiques
inévitable auquel l'humanité va devoir
faire face
premier défi un défi technologique
l'homme se rend de plus en plus
dépendant des machines cela veut dire
que les industries doivent et devront
constamment surveillé ce monde dans
lequel nous évoluons car ce sont elles
qui insuffle du pouvoir aux machines et
deuxième défi un défi humain
demain parmi les hommes les plus
talentueux s'en sortiront peut-être vous
l'avez déjà vu à un précédentes aides
laurent alexandre médecins scientifiques
et prospectiviste dit que l'argent est
l'origine sociale n'ayant plus
d'importance dans un monde où la
richesse économique et créer par la
machine la plus grande inégalité qui
nous attend pour le siècle qui arrive
c'est l'inégalité de qi la course à
l'intelligence va mettre l'humanité en
compétition je parle de cuit parce que
c'est le seul métriques précis que nous
possédons aujourd'hui pour mesurer
l'intelligence et qui est collectivement
reconnue par les experts
cet indicateur est en train de créer des
écarts considérables
logiquement il sera toujours pris en
compte demain pour quantifier et évaluer
la capacité des individus à générer de
l'innovation mais très heureusement pour
nous il sera mis en perspective avec de
très nombreux indicateurs qualitatifs
dont le qi quotient émotionnel que l'on
analysera et que l'on apprendra à
muscler de mieux en mieux grâce aux
progrès des neurosciences
grâce à la recherche sur la plasticité
cognitives c'est à dire notre capacité à
apprendre de nouvelles choses et ça
c'est fondamental qu'il y ait demain des
personnes
les agiles intuitive artistes et
créative parce que le but de demain ce
sera de remettre de l'humain au centre
d'une société qui devient de plus en
plus numérique est de plus en plus
technologique
alors tout cela développer ce type de
compétences pour survivre demain ce ne
doit pas devenir un facteur de stress
qui nous empêchent d'agir ce type de
compétence n'est pas inné ça ça prend ça
s'enseigne ça se travaille et tout le
monde peut progresser à partir de
n'importe quel niveau
c'est juste qu'il faut bien comprendre
qu'on doit se préparer à ce monde là dès
maintenant les écoles et les universités
aujourd'hui ne prépare pas à cela elle
continue d'enseigner l'indiscutable
alors que le monde est en train de
changer à une vitesse phénoménale
c'est ce qui fait dire à beaucoup
d'experts que de nombreuses écoles que
nous connaissons aujourd'hui vont
disparaître dans les années à venir pour
laisser place à un nouveau paradigme
plus ouvert plus humain plus énergisant
et plus créatif et c'est déjà visible
aujourd'hui de nouveaux modèles
éducatifs sont en train d'émerger pour
former pour préparer les individus à ce
futur et à cette nouvelle ère de
l'emploi et moi je veux en faire partie
participer à créer l'école du futur mais
aussi en bénéficier
c'est l'emploi que je me prépare pour
aujourd'hui et pour demain
j'ai compris qu'à mon âge et qu'à mon
époque travailler pour et dans l'ancien
monde n'avait plus de sens
inconsciemment ces dernières années je
me suis dirigé vers une porte de sortie
après un parcours scolaire en
dents-de-scie quand j'ai terminé mes
études
une fois que j'étais diplômés et donc au
chômage j'ai enfin commencé à faire ce
que j'aimais ce qui me passionne
je n'ai pas recherché de travail je n'ai
répondu à aucune offre d'emploi mais
j'ai détecté une entreprise qui
m'inspiraient en fait c'était surtout
une personne qui m'inspiraient son
directeur général patrick molle je
n'avais pas fait les études adéquates
mais je ne me suis pas laissé le choix
il fallait absolument que je rejoigne
cette entreprise alors je les contacter
pour lui propose
de travailler pour lui il m'a laissé me
créer ma place au sein d'un poste qui
n'existait pas avant que j'arrive tout
était nouveau pour moi et je m'entends
encore lui répondre oui à tout ce qui me
demandait alors que dans ma tête je
n'avais aucune idée de comment faire je
n'avais aucune clé aucun cahier des
charges
à chaque fois je disais oui je paniquais
pendant une demi heure et après je me
disais tu sais pas comment tu vas le
faire mais tu vas le faire
et grâce à cette technique plutôt
efficace j'ai progressivement développé
de nouvelles compétences qui touchent
des domaines que je ne connaissais pas
auparavant comme le business ou le
design et quand j'ai réalisé que j'avais
réussi à inventer
mon métier est ma valeur dans
l'entreprise j'ai compris que la suite
de ma vie professionnelle n'allait être
qu'une répétition de ce même scénario un
renouvellement perpétuel de compétences
et de sens et je crois que c'est ça
qu'il faut que l'on enseigne à l'école
de demain
la flexibilité face aux changements et
la liberté de se réinventer
quand patrick m'a dit qu'il voulait
créer cette école
j'ai immédiatement décidé de rejoindre
son équipe
j'ai dit oui oui pour créer l'école du
futur une école qui embrasse le 21e
siècle
une école qui réveille et qui révèle les
individus à leurs propres talents à leur
propre passion à leur propre vocation et
qui les aident à en faire leur métier
leurs emplois pour demain car nous
sommes dans une nouvelle ère une
nouvelle ère de l'emploi une nouvelle
ère de l'apprendre et donc une nouvelle
ère pour l'humanité posez-vous bien
cette question à quoi allez vous vous
employez vous demain on a vu de
formidable exemple aujourd'hui hothead
avec des gens qui se sont inventé leur
propre métier qui ont lâché leurs
dragons qui ont ouvert des dragonnes riz
qui ont fait pousser des champignons
bioluminescence qui ont fait de la
musique avec leur bouche essayer de
commencer maintenant à capitaliser sur
vos passions préparez-vous à arrêter de
travailler
et préparez vous à créer votre futur
merci